[Music]  Selena Gomez and the weekend go on a  magical date at the happiest place on  earth it's a great feeling  the pop star power couple was spotted at  Disneyland Sunday night  one fan capturing this video of Selena  and The Weeknd strolling through the  California amusement park holding hands  [Music]  and I witnessed LVT they were there with  their bodyguards and another couple  adding there was a lot of PDA holding  hands kissing can't keep my hands to  myself the adorable duo reportedly  munched on churros and hopped on rides  like Space Mountain and Pirates of the  Caribbean but according to the source  there was one adventure Selina opted out  of quote Selena skipped out riding  Indiana Jones while everyone else in the  group did she stayed outside with the  bodyguard feel free more than I've ever  felt in my whole life  Selena recently gushed about her star  boy beau in the September issue of  InStyle magazine calling him her best  friend  [Music]